and then there's this like
this yellow pudding
right it's straight yellow
and it's in a big serving tray right
it's a buffet line type of thing so i
just lay next to me i'm like excuse me
um can you tell me what this yellow
pudding is what is this
right and she goes oh
this is tartar
do you know what tartar is tartar sauce
do you know tartar have you ever had
mayonnaise and relish
tartare and i'm like i just spoke to you
in english in english in five four three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast if you are a first-time listener
this is
also known as [ __ ] uh [ __ ] monster
which is
it was the original name of the podcast
really
i need some soup what
it was
it was going to be called [ __ ] monsters
and it was supposed to be the cookie
monster with two fortune cookies in his
hands
with the chinese
squid podcast with podcast earbuds
headphones on you had a a spectrum of
ideas yeah the absolute worst one
it's somewhere right in the middle yeah
it's gonna be called [ __ ] monsters that
people advise me not to me milk milk
but uh yeah people advised me not to do
that number one they said that it was a
little too um
kind of cornered the market on just
asian stuff right cause you talk about
everything right and they also said it
was borderline offensive
also you were just coming off the set of
goog
[Laughter]
by the way saying that's the movie you
were in yeah yeah dude did i ever tell
you um
so
years ago you know you know we did kim
jong-il together right so if you guys
don't know one of the
i i did this character kim jong-il and
then there was uh this video that i did
which was one of which kind of evolved
the style of what the kim jong-il videos
were because i just shot it by myself
yeah and i just set up a tripod and i
just said [ __ ] and so it was
actually it wasn't the first time i ever
met you was in seattle yeah we shot the
kim jong-il in seattle that was a dope
ass time exactly the first time we met
and then we clicked instantly and we
went to tiggs and we got drunk together
even in the editing process i was like
look in the script this and that but if
we switched it this way and then you
were totally on board i was like this
guy [ __ ] gets it
yeah that makes sense yeah so many
people are so anal about how they write
something even in like youtube skits
they're like no it's like this yeah this
and they'll ruin a [ __ ] joke because
it's what they say yeah
i'm not too particular about that it's
more like
especially like in the creative process
or just anything that you'll do
you're never gonna be a hundred percent
right
right it's it's impossible right
some things is taste and preference and
other times it's just it's just better
you just need other people's ideas
sometimes so you can take the credit
yeah
yeah i'm [ __ ] around
no literally david has never done this
i'm just alluding to the other people
i've worked with yeah it's pretty cool
because like now it's just like
yeah when we work together like you'll
sometimes i don't understand structure
very well you know because i'm i'm more
of a joke guy
sometimes i think too much about the
joke where i'm not thinking about the
structure and how things make sense on
camera you know which which is you know
i i just don't know that type of stuff
so as an editor i i have i see foresight
i see it how it's gonna be edited as
we're shooting and i'm like we need to
fill this spot or we gotta say something
here to transition it or whatever like
that's the kinds of things i see i think
that's why we work so well again yeah
yeah and it's always more fun and
collaborative that way too like if
you're so just like staunch on one idea
or one concept number one most likely
it's not going to turn out that well
yeah like even uh like like [ __ ] when we
shot the structure of that film
completely flipped from what the script
was to what the editing was right and
that's because of the editing team like
this doesn't make sense yeah when we saw
the first edit it was ac the film was
actually chronological
and it was very flat but when we started
flipping things around different
locations and it just it was way more
exciting yeah it just it just edited a
lot better that way
so you know you just can't be married to
all these [ __ ] ideas
what the [ __ ] was i going to say earlier
cookie monster it was [ __ ] monsters and
then oh so speaking of like really
offensive ideas
so
with the kim jong-il character years ago
um a lot of networks were really
interested in making kim jong-il an
actual series oh wow
uh it was really popular at the time so
i had the misfortune of having this
being shopped around and wanting to be
picked up during the time that north
korea were they were hacking people's
files oh [ __ ] that's all sony yes the
whole the interview
exactly yeah so there was a specific
network out there that wanted to pick it
up and literally they were like this is
hilarious this is crazy
we want to do this and then the sony
network thing happened they [ __ ] iced
them all right they're like nope we're
not going to take a risk on this because
if they did that to sony they'll [ __ ]
do it to us [ __ ]
but the funny thing is is like when you
go into a room and you're pitching these
ideas a lot of the stuff that you do
will get watered down i eat something
like fresh off the boat right fresh off
the boat was probably something a lot
more true to its nature oh yeah because
eddie huang's father was a gangster yeah
and randall park is not exactly you know
what i mean yeah so there's stuff like
that
well for when you're in these riding
rooms or what i was told is like listen
balls to the wall shoot whatever idea
that you want and let them water it down
yeah so i remember
and this is like one of these patrice
o'neill moments where he says like half
the room when you do this when you do
comedy should be dying laughing and the
other one should be mortified and that's
exactly what happened yeah so i pitched
this so the idea of kim jong-il as a
character is kim jong-il in and of
itself he's not really a bad guy he's
just a guy that's [ __ ] ignorant
he is told that everything he does and
everything he touches is gold
so
his perception of himself is a lot more
heightened than his actual reality yes
and so that's why you see in kim jong-il
that's why he's number one everything
he's the number one husband and you find
out he's not the number one husband
right number one singer he's not the
number one singer but he doesn't know
any better right so in this series it
was supposed to be a half reality it was
supposed to be like um a reality tv show
like the office like a mockumentary like
a mockumentary but more like um
borat
okay yeah
you're supposed to be like borat with
training actors and and then and then
you go out and interact with the real
world though in these situations exactly
so the first episode this is the one
that i pitched in this was my favorite
[ __ ] episode i remember when i was
pitching this idea these the the writers
that they were trying to that they were
lining up for me they were crying
laughing they were cracking the [ __ ] up
they're like dude this is what i want to
write for right
but some of the execs were like what the
[ __ ] is this crazy so the first episode
i did i remember i was pitching with
this guy and i really liked this guy
because he understood where i was coming
from he was bouncing off ideas off of me
and it was getting crazier and crazier
yeah and so the first episode was
supposed to be kim jong-il number one uh
self-defense uh teacher for women
right
and so first you take away their rights
dude so the first episode he is a
self-defense teacher uh for sex
offenders
it's not when someone's coming to kick
there so it's
it's to protect sex sex offenders
against women who have had self-defense
training
and you're telling me this didn't pass
it's just no green light
the first episode it's him and so this
is like a borat thing so it's half
trained actors have not yes yeah and so
you're in
i gotta find the script somewhere i
don't know where the [ __ ] it is but the
first episode he's a self uh
defense teacher for sex offenders and
there's a bunch of women who think this
is for women
so they're walking in but they see half
the room are a bunch of creepy guys and
they're all actors okay right but some
of the women are actors as well too yeah
and so
like the first thing that kim jong-un
said is that today we are going to teach
you how to depends
right
and then i have a [ __ ] anti-rape kit
and then the anti-let's not say aunt
let's not say the word rape let's say
anti self defense kid right apologies
um
inside there is was pliers a small
bottle of milk
right the pliers were to break the uh
rape whistle
[Laughter]
and the small bottle of milk was for
pepper spray for your eyes
so smooth
yeah okay okay i see i see why it wasn't
green but yeah so this is so here's the
thing though and i want people to listen
to this thoroughly
the idea of this is that we're not
celebrating this guy he is a [ __ ]
idiot yeah and he's clearly in the wrong
nobody agrees with him right so the
people who aren't actors and actresses
they're they're gonna freak out like
what the [ __ ] is this about right
and so like you'll see and i'm setting
up the scenario i get one of the male
actors and then one of the female
actresses right and then he's she's
supposed to defend against his attacks
and he takes the ripples and crushes it
right she sprays it to the eye and he
puts the milk in his eye and they go
number one depends is always
extra offense right and then he just
[ __ ] tackles her right and then we
end that scenario and in the back it was
supposed to be this weird acronym i
forgot what it was but it was a stupid
[ __ ] acronym and it was highly
offensive but in these episodes because
he doesn't understand how this world
works he thinks that he took a garyvee
seminar about creating a a business
about stuff that people don't have so
creating things inventions are creating
stuff that people don't know that they
need and that's what he said so that's
the garyvee seminar that he heard and
that's why he created this thing right
but he doesn't know about the social
norms yeah and so what happens is at the
end of the class the female actors beat
the [ __ ] out of kim jong-il right right
and then he doesn't know what's
happening he's crying and they explain
to him like listen like these aren't
good people and he's like but i but a
gary b told me
you have to build the invention it's
something that you don't know what you
need right now
you know
and then you know he then he starts to
realize this is really terrible and he
goes around and apologizing that he
becomes a feminist and he starts you
know supporting women right so there is
a moral to the story and it's just that
he's not celebrated for this stuff he's
just a [ __ ] it's like borat yes yes
borat is a [ __ ] right so many people
don't understand borat like that right
because
borat is
okay um what's the real guy sasha cohn
joshua shot baron cohen
he's actually a trained
like mime
like he oh really yes he is a
classically trained clown
legit clown right that [ __ ] makes
sense so what is the purpose of a clown
i think people have forgotten what a
purpose of a clown is
right uh because they just look so scary
and creepy yeah they just turn into
horror movies
in actuality what like a clown's job is
that they're like expert mimes at the
same time
but like they're dressed up in all that
makeup and then ridiculous clothes right
to show that they are gestures they are
goofs right
but their job is to make you
look dumber than them
so they play so dumb the idea is that
sasha baron cohen in his borah character
or any of his men's ali g
and bruno and all those characters and
uh there to pretty much what he
if you watch it it's so [ __ ] like
genius psychologist
psychological like offensiveness yeah
where he makes himself so dumb
that someone else thinks he's obviously
smarter than them but to actually
communicate with them they have to dumb
themselves down yeah right yeah yeah and
so that's why these crazy important
people like like senators and like um
like celebrities whether they fall for
his traps because they don't know that
he's playing this character and that's
why it's so genius because he plays a
clown where what he's really doing even
though he's an idiot as borat he's an
idiot
all of his characters are idiots they're
dumb they're dumb but they're not
supposed to be celebrated yes the point
is to show that either you whoever's
he's interviewing that whatever you
think or believe in politicians
politicians all of that [ __ ] is to show
that your [ __ ] is pretentious it's fake
it doesn't really it's it it doesn't
help anybody and you're a fool you're
even dumber than i am right now as this
weird immigrant what he's doing is
is trying to live up to the american
uh i guess values are all that's the
american dream but showings the flaws in
it
that's why the borough mammoth
borat movies are so genius to me
first borat it's so insane to me and the
reason why it did so well is because
nobody knew who sasha baron cohen was
right so there was a huge challenge in
this shooting so many people fell for it
from the first yeah right but the second
movie was so much harder because
everyone i heard it was [ __ ]
difficult because everybody knew who
borat was yeah and i think over time
like borat let's just say it's a cult
classic now yeah it is a [ __ ] cult
classic and so it's hard not to know
what borat is maybe in the next 50 years
you could somebody else can do it and
then it'll have like that same effect
again but as of right now sasha baron
cohen is still very popular he did bruno
he did all these different iterations so
like there was stuff like i could tell
it was hard for them to shoot like he
they just couldn't get it done oh yeah
so they had to go into obscure america
you know
yeah exactly yeah
they filmed in the area you know i
always talk [ __ ] about the crazy [ __ ]
i've seen in borat too they filmed in
the area i live in oh for real yeah
that's what so he dresses up as a
heck yokel and
that was it in washington
and those two guys in the cabin he was
staying with
that was in washington that's a
hilarious standard so like as i was
watching i was like holy [ __ ] god i
i'm so thankful he came to this area to
expose his people for what they think
and believe in that's [ __ ] insane
yeah
and if you watch bar at 2 it's kind of
hard to watch there's a lot of cringe
movies really hard to watch sometimes
really hard to watch but it's like one
of the sweetest movies you ever see too
the [ __ ] character arc of his
daughter yeah it's so sweet while it's
like what the [ __ ] is happening the
first one was because
people didn't know who he was i was
trying to watch it there was moments i
had to pause because i was getting
goosebumps because i was like oh like
this is so hard to watch hard to watch
but which shows the [ __ ] balls he has
and he's not laughing yeah
my lovely brain farts to continue to
support this podcast remember this
podcast is brought to you by
ipvanish did you know that browsing
online uses incognito mode doesn't
actually protect your privacy that's
right without added security you might
as well give away all your private data
to hackers advertisers your isp and
other prying eyes you dummies what are
you doing you're out there browsing out
there thinking that you're safe but
you're not everybody's snooping and
duping on your stuff you need to get a
vpn and you need to do it with ip vanish
that's why i use ipvanishvpn to make it
easy to stay truly private and secure on
the internet you can use ipvanish on
unlimited devices without sacrificing on
speed your computers tablet phones even
devices like your fire stick when you're
streaming media whether i'm at home or
in public i don't go online anymore
without using ipvanish so remember my
friends go to ipvanish.com brain and use
promotional code brain and claim your
70 savings that's ipvanish.com
brain
how is he not [ __ ] laughing have you
seen who is america dude that was the
series that he did right yes yes with
the whole self defense the already yeah
that's so good
dude when he was doing the whole dildo
out the thing by my date i was like this
is not real and these people are really
like going for it and doing this [ __ ]
right how how does he do this that's the
kind of mind games baron cohen can play
that's why he's [ __ ] genius how he
can get people to stoop like their
[ __ ] intelligence lower to expose
themselves because most people walk
around with
like at least some kind of awareness
yeah where there's manners right but
when you take away like
like uh
not take away but let's say you build a
false sense of a sense of a safe space
yeah it makes people expose themselves
and he's so good at doing it's so true
when you say that where people kind of
dumb themselves down because they
believe the person is stupid and they
kind of lower like it's the same thing
when somebody thinks that they can't
speak english right right like i've seen
people come and talk to my parents you
know and they're not trying to be rude
but you know inherently it's just very
weird yeah they go like okay this is
where you go it's like listen
if they don't speak english
whether you say it's slower faster
they're not gonna understand it doesn't
matter how fast you say it or not right
so it's just i would always look at that
i'm like
if somebody came up to me right and they
started speaking cantonese right and
they go oh
hi yeah i see him you know i just
started going really fast i was very
racist
but if they if they go really slow with
it i'm like i still don't understand it
doesn't matter i wonder why we do that
i don't know i think it's um i gotta i
gotta say sometimes it's part of
like a superiority complex yeah to be
honest like even so when i was in hawaii
doing my missionary training on this
base in kona
um we have a like every breakfast lunch
dinner we everybody eats together no
matter what class is a big university
but there's only one lunch line right
yeah and that week they have they're
they're serving shark
oh [ __ ] yeah
and you know me and seafood i can't do
that [ __ ] or whatever right so i'm just
going through the line and i'm getting
everything but the fish
and then there's this like
this yellow pudding
right it's straight yellow
and it's in a big serving tray right
it's a buffet line type of thing right
you go through the line pick up your
portion
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is this
yellow pudding or whatever so there's
this white lady next to me obviously
we're all missionaries we're all like
doing missionary work
and so we're all they're all super
christian
and
so i just laid next to me i'm like
excuse me
um can you tell me what this yellow
pudding is what is this
right and she goes oh
this is
tartar do you know what tartar is
tartar sauce do you know tartar have you
ever had mayonnaise and relish
tartare and i'm like i just spoke to you
in english in english in a perfect thing
maybe i have a weird l.a kind of like
accent or some [ __ ] but like
what the [ __ ] i just asked you what this
was they were like tart but the thing is
bless her heart she was trying to be
super nice yeah but she was talking to
me like i was deaf dude i would have
hammed it up dude i would have hammed it
up so bad whoa do you know what this is
what do you say i would have been like
this old japanese
yeah like i was what the [ __ ] but that's
the thing like i don't know what it is
but people think that when someone can't
understand you they gotta talk slower
and louder like you're like handicapped
yes like i don't understand the language
i'm not [ __ ] deaf yeah like what are
you talking about i mean my problem
being like i just spoke perfect [ __ ]
english to you
what the funny thing is it doesn't even
matter if it's like that it even works
the other way around so you know z it's
he our buddies you've seen him on the
podcast years ago but uh z is a musician
friend of ours but he's chinese swedish
yes so he speaks swedish so we're going
to an ikea and i'm with him
who's the [ __ ] ikea there's an old
swedish man up front he's clearly has a
thick swedish accent right and then z is
excited because he gets to speak swedish
yeah right and he starts speaking to him
in swedish and the guy just goes
okay uh in here
i'm like
he's speaking swedish to you speaks
right
he won't return the face
he's speaking back to him in this broken
english that nobody understands i'm like
what the [ __ ] is that i was like looking
at z i was like what is that he goes i
don't [ __ ] know
i couldn't understand him in english
i was like i don't know what the [ __ ]
he's saying in english like [ __ ] was he
swedish maybe he was finnish
i think [ __ ] z z speaks like uh
polish swedish uh cantonese mandarin and
english damn these weird little leg ups
not obscure obviously like cantonese and
mandarin are like the most popular
languages but i guess like um where he
worked at they speak they spoke polish
so he learned it right he's like he
speaks like five languages sure well
i wonder what he's thinking about what's
going on out there because that's
eastern europe basically oh yeah so
we're going to talk about that it's it's
weird like i kind of want to discuss
this only because of just
how [ __ ] sad it is and it's the
biggest news in the world i mean we're
looking at this is going to change all
our lives
and it's not and that's the pandemic's
just about over i know
isn't that the weird thing it's like
what the [ __ ] is happening and now we're
facing world war iii yeah
literally yeah and i'm not sure too if
people understand the gravity of
the situation of the state of the world
right now aside from pandemic right so
if you guys don't know what's happening
right now there's a literal war going on
right now
in ukraine and russia yeah and
i'm trying to read up the first thing i
googled right and as i'm seeing all this
stuff and look i'm not worldly like most
people are so i don't know
what the relationship status is between
ukraine and russia in all honesty if i'm
going to be 100 honest i thought it was
the same thing yeah
yeah they both speak russian yeah so i i
didn't know right so my understanding is
that
the ukraine
and many many other states um used to be
part of russia the ussr the soviet union
and in 91 right
91 yeah the the well the soviet union
fell right the the uh berlin wall came
down and everything communists within
the european
you know areas kind of fell
right and in turn what happened was that
all these little uh
states that belong to the soviet union
um
basically fractioned off and became
independent they became their own
countries
and so specifically ukraine was very
heavy towards being a democratic country
right and i don't mean that like like
democrats and republic like democratic
meaning that they vote you know for
their leadership and and basically the
normal first
world style is a many
democratically elected government right
yeah elected leadership elected
leadership
and over the years apparently there's
been a lot of turmoil between russia and
um the ukraine so in 2014
um
there was a
basically a pr they ousted the president
so they had just elected this new
president
and um it turned out when he when he was
elected he started
[ __ ] acting like a puppet for the
russian government he was like a puppet
president it turned out he was very
pro-putin pro-russia
and he started um changing
government policies to help favor
russian
influence into the ukraine and because
of that the ukrainian people [ __ ]
ousted him and that's how much they felt
about this guy yeah right being a puppet
president
and once they did that in response
here's the thing
if if it was real or not then i don't
know why this involves russia yeah but
because they asked the president that's
when russia annexed crimea
you know you heard all about that crimea
is this peninsula in the ukraine they
just took it over
right and now it became a russian state
and it's basically occupied by russia
right now
and
over
a whole nother [ __ ] fish a barrel and
i i don't know if that was the right i
told you we just make things up
the whole another thing about that is
that
there was a
an american named paul manafort
who was
the
campaign
manager leader head of this puppet
president's
campaign right
and basically which means he was working
with the russian government
to
you know put in this puppet president
into the ukraine
this guy's name is paul manafort
paul manafort was [ __ ] trump's 2016
presidential campaign manager oh
that's why all this [ __ ] russia gay
[ __ ] started happening because that guy
was actually still a russian agent while
he was managing trump's campaign for
presidency
and that's also why he actually went to
jail for that and that's why although
robert mueller mueller the whole
yeah all that [ __ ] they're saying it's a
hoax it's [ __ ] real oh [ __ ] so many
people keep saying it's a hoax it's
[ __ ] real wow right so that campaign
manager of this ukrainian public
president was a
campaign manager for trump
and what's happening right now
trump is advocating for russia and putin
to this day still and throughout his
whole presidency he was [ __ ] sucking
putin's dick
holy [ __ ] yeah so that [ __ ] is real
anyways that's a side note that's a
whole nother thing but that was the
start of a really big conflict like with
like military conflict when they annexed
crimea
right and basically what's happening
through putin
is that
he believes that ukraine is still a
state of russia that they are not an
independent country they have no
sovereignty that they belong to russia
that is the whole deal with apparently
with them invading saying you're
becoming russia again that's what's
going on oh holy [ __ ] it's as if
maybe in the civil war uh texas became
its own country right because texas
basically acts like they are their own
yeah republic of texas
and let's say today we're like you know
what [ __ ] that [ __ ] you're america you
speak our language you look like us you
hold all these american values all this
[ __ ]
you know you're american and then the us
government with all its military
surrounded texas and invaded yeah you
know it's kind of like that that's
what's happening it was a former state
of russia it gained its independence and
now russia wants it back through force
it's so crazy because i was reading um
it's a very frightening statement where
putin basically warned
all allied all allied countries
like listen if you step in
this is going to be the worst thing
you'll ever do in the history of the
world like nothing unseen some words
along that line yeah which is
so much like even scarier when put when
trump said fire and fury against north
korea right because you know trump we
know he wasn't gonna pull that [ __ ]
trigger but putin he's a [ __ ] xkgb agent
yes he has literally killed people with
his own hands for goddamn sure
you know
like he is total authoritarian
like nemesis what's going on he's
straight up evil yes like he does not
[ __ ] care and he was basically saying
i'm looking for the quote right now but
it kind of gave me like chills down my
spine like the way it was translated it
was like whoever tries to stand in our
way to create threats for our country
and people should know russia's response
will be immediate and lead you the
consequences you have never encountered
in your history
which basically what have we not
encountered in our history world war
three
nuclear weapons yep yeah
world war three it's
like that is [ __ ] frightening dude
yeah a guy like that who will actually
pull the trigger
is yeah we should be
on our toes about this and honestly now
i'm looking at stuff like is there going
to be assassinations
or like attempts at people's like lives
so the president has announced that
there are russian agents who have made
it into the ukrainian
capital kiev
yeah
and that his life is in danger he made a
public announcement with that that the
russian agents have already made their
way in
holy [ __ ]
man i saw this video that [ __ ]
actually i was like tearing up before we
started doing this podcast it was
literally
a uh ukrainian father yeah and i saw
that at the train station at the train
station it's [ __ ] real yeah like it's
just the daughter and the mother and
he's the daughter's crying and he's like
kissing his daughter bawling his eyes
out because he has to stay back and
fight for ukraine but he has to send his
family to safety because ukraine's under
martial law right now and they announced
that
men from 18 to 60 years old cannot leave
their country yeah 60
60 year old that's crazy and even like
you know i scroll through reddit and
there's always random feeds
and then there was a off my chest post i
don't know if you know that subreddit
it's just people when they confess like
things there are people writing about
how scared they are they're from uk they
live in ukraine
and and they're saying i have to join
the army i can't leave this country
other
someone else was talking about how they
try to leave with their family but then
the airport is being bombed like this is
some real [ __ ] [ __ ]
i wonder like how this the
i mean we're young too but like
let's say um a generation before us
right like young 20s
like 15 16 17 year olds you know even
like young 20 year olds
what do they think about this because
they they're growing up in a world where
all this information is so accessible
and they've heard about disaster after
disaster but for us we
we're kind of in the middle between all
this stuff right the generation before 9
11 yeah everyone else was born after 9
11 this this younger generation than us
right exactly we didn't see a [ __ ]
world threat like this yeah since right
which is it it's giving me those weirdly
like
just that weird queasy feeling in my
stomach just like 9 11. yeah you know
what i mean and when when somebody like
putin basically threatens nuclear war
and then i see
like i'm not knocking on these kids or
whatever what not right
this is not what this conversation is
about
um it's just weird to see like
hear this and then you see
you know
bts tick tock dance
[Laughter]
my lovely genius farts let's continue to
keep this podcast sponsored by
supporting our sponsors this podcast is
brought to you by the lost debate
whenever you look for news you may feel
forced to choose between echo chambers
and mainstream media and conspiracy
obsessed alternative media well guess
what that's why you need to check out
the lost debate it's a podcast youtube
show for political eclectics who want to
escape their media bubbles and engage in
good faith with ideas from across the
political
spectrum my friends the lost debate is
hosted by
hope did hosted by ravi gupta corey
bradford and ricky schlundt so if you
guys want to go ahead and check them out
you should they cover the latest news
ideas and trends that mainstream media
constantly overlooks and instead of
being at each other's throats they focus
on bringing new perspectives to the
table in constructive debates that sound
less like crossfire and more like
discussions between real people join the
conversation check out the lost debate
today new episodes drop twice a week
search for the lost debate on youtube or
wherever you get your podcast
i thought you were gonna say some
[ __ ] serious [ __ ] or whatever
i mean it is serious though like yeah
what's up with that why are you guys
moving on with your lives dude i'm at
risk
um
do you know what's going on yeah you
know and i'm like okay maybe it was like
earlier in the day right because early
in the day i did an instagram story
where i was upset i gained some weight
yes
you know and then after i got off that
story you know days yeah i was going on
and i looked at my apple news stuff
started popping up yeah and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is going on right now
i'm seeing all these photos i'm seeing
these videos you know khalif actually
stayed in ukraine for three weeks i
think he was doing a missionary work or
something he stayed with the family out
there and then he downloaded the
whatsapp app and he saw their contacts
so he just asked them what's going on
are they okay they said they're [ __ ]
frightened to death they have no idea
what's gonna happen to them yeah that is
so [ __ ] scary i mean you're talking
about the younger generation who's just
in america who's just living their lives
you know like continuing with their tick
tock dances
but like you got to think about it this
way too dude i just said the
martial law requires
all ukrainian men from 18 to 60 to stay
right can you imagine someone's turning
18 tomorrow
some 17 year old boy he's going to turn
18 tomorrow and he can't leave the
country you know
like that's the car shoot a [ __ ] gun
and fight yeah and the reason why it
goes up to 60 is apparently i read this
on on reddit like
anyone who's 51 and older
has had military mandatory military
training by the former soviet government
oh so they're the ones who know how to
use use weapons they're more useful than
a 20 year old who comes in who has no
idea who the [ __ ] is going oh my god so
that's the situation they're in it's
[ __ ] scary
it's weird because like when i listen to
um like i follow uh tim kennedy right
former mma
um ufc fighter right uh like uh army
ranger yeah right special forces that's
[ __ ] that yeah
badass yeah but he's very adamant in
talking about like
um and i know a lot of people who you
know when you read online they disagree
about this statement about america being
a shining beacon of justice right
and for somebody who was an army ranger
he has seen a lot of like these
different atrocities that happen uh you
know in a different world yeah because
the two perspectives behind this and i'm
not putting my two cents into anything
right now you guys decide for yourselves
about what you think about this yeah
it's the idea of yes they are atrocities
but that's how those other people live
where do we come in and and tell them
how not to live their lives that's their
problems we have issues of our own yeah
and then you have somebody like tim
kennedy
who
really loves america and his identity of
being an american especially somebody
who was a soldier who has fought for
this country says no there is there's
evil in this world and we as a country
who have the means to protect other
people in this world we need to do it
yeah and it's so hard for somebody who's
a civilian like me to sit back and i can
never say this i can never say like yeah
we should go out there because i'm not
the one going out there no i'm not the
one shooting guns i'm not the one
risking my [ __ ] life i'm not the one
leaving my family behind so like when we
see these situations and it really comes
to dawn i mean when people say hey thank
these people out there who are fighting
for your country and this is what it is
because we're not the ones who have to
put our lives out there there's kids
right now in ukraine from 18 to [ __ ]
60. yeah that's what it is could you
imagine and everybody anybody's who's
listening this right now that's within
this age gap and that's us too that we
would that i somebody who just
was pitching a show about a guy named
kim jong-il yeah
you know what i mean protecting uh
sexual offenders sex offenders from
women yeah and now i have to learn how
to defend myself and then protect this
country and kill somebody just do like
your grandpa dude and just go find an
island and hide in there dude right be
just like my grandpa dude on another
podcast i gotta update you about that
whole thing
because i i went back and i was like
dude you know so much about your family
i'm just going to ask my dad about this
stuff i found out so much more [ __ ] yeah
like i was like oh this is pretty
[ __ ] nuts right that's the thing with
korean parents not telling us about the
history even though it's crazy [ __ ]
interesting yeah like i didn't even know
um when i was a kid
my grandma and grandpa i barely i don't
remember this too much but when he said
it it kind of sparked something in my
head whenever my grandma and grandpa
would argue with each other in front of
us they would do it in japanese oh [ __ ]
yeah
because they only grew up learning
japanese yeah so they would speak to
each other in japanese right so we
wouldn't understand what the [ __ ] they
were saying but they would yell at each
other in japanese so i i want to talk
about this too the oddity of the
situation that's going on here not not
oddity it's just kind of rare because
um
you know
we have seen war in our lifetime and
throughout history when you see war it's
usually
one foreign land against another foreign
land and it could be because of
different religion different ethno
religious things are all all these
factors because of what they look like
right
this current situation
they are also speaking russian they look
like russians yeah they were a former
state of russia you know this is why
like putin has this
manifest destiny kind of idea like no
they are russian they are our people
we're gonna just take it back that's the
biggest thing the other thing being like
lies about them having uh weapons of
mass destruction militarizing and stuff
like that yeah
and so that's what's so different
because
that's what i i'm starting to see about
what's happening with this and what
happened in the past now the usa our
country us americans
we invaded iraq
twice
the first time was in a legit
altruistic reason because they were
invading kuwait in 19 in the 90s in the
early 90s and george bush senior went
and stopped that [ __ ] you know
now the second time we went
was really weird
it was what was the reasons why we were
going in weapons of mass destruction
weapons of mass destruction and also
that al qaeda is in iraq when they were
they were in afghanistan you know
and we look at it today like why we went
to iraq in the first place it was a
whole lot of [ __ ] and in the end we
took a lot of oil billions yeah billions
of dollars worth of oil you know if we
didn't go to iraq our gas prices would
be much much much more expensive yeah
right
so
i look back at those times and i was a
senior in high school when we first got
into iraq
and there was a big debate about
anti-war sentiment and and pro-war
right and growing up where i grew up
you know the middle of nowhere very much
red state all this [ __ ] like it was all
pro-war and anyone who was against the
war were [ __ ]
libtards you know
like pacifists basically the word was
just [ __ ] [ __ ] all that [ __ ] yeah
chickens
and then um you i don't know if you've
seen this but there are massive protests
in moscow and st petersburg yeah right
which is really from russian people
awesome to see yeah
now
i i
i
just see that as it's so much more
different because they i think they seem
to see more of a link like these are
human beings right but in the american
case what will be told about middle
easterners terrorists yeah right
like
all sorts of racist [ __ ] you can you
it'll pack up and stop and stack up with
all the things that they said about
middle easterners that make it look like
us versus them they're different than us
we dehumanize them to justify why we
were in iraq yeah and this time around
you're looking at what putin's doing
and
they are essentially the same people you
know it's almost close to like looking
at north and south korea we're we're
both koreans yeah you know they're
they're i'm not gonna say they're both
russian because the ukrainians don't
identify russians but they both speak
the same language
they have a very long shared history and
i'm pretty sure too
there are people right now who have
family there that are in russia in
russia yeah russian ukrainian families
and they're like to my family's there
yeah you know so it's
it's kind of insane when i saw those
protests because i think a lot of a lot
of the times too when they see a leader
makes a move it's a representation of
what everybody believes in the country
yeah which is not true not true at all
right not true at all like how
government and how people move are two
sometimes two very separate things and a
lot of times more than sometimes right
and when you see all these thousands of
protesters coming out crying like saying
this is wrong this is wrong this is
wrong and you see them arresting them
taking them away dragging them away i
think there was like
at the time when i was reading it was
like 1400 something people were arrested
that were protesting
you know i saw a video of a girl crying
on on like a tick tock story video or
some [ __ ] like her mom was [ __ ] shot
in the head they went to the grocery
store
and they came out trying to get away
from their [ __ ] tanks and the tank
was coming to run them over so they ran
away and they started shooting at them
and they blew her mom's head off that's
insane dude regular girl like you and i
you know and she had to go out and see
it on the internet regular girl like me
and you yeah
yeah you know we can go to the you know
women's restroom and all that [ __ ] yeah
but
yeah it's like
yeah these are these are all people i
mean the the other spectrum of that i'm
also seeing the argument because i
brought up
usa and iraq situation yeah
there is so much more sympathy for these
ukrainians than any than the us had for
[ __ ] iraqis they're humans too yeah
and i'm gonna straight up say it there
is a racial barrier i think it was
because it was happening to brown people
a lot of people didn't give a [ __ ]
but when you start seeing eastern
european type of people and these
and because it's such a modern first-gen
like first world country you say this
shouldn't happen but it's okay to happen
in vietnam it's okay to happen in iraq
it's okay to happen in these other
countries with dark-skinned people
yeah you know
like not saying that we shouldn't keep
on
fighting to say that this is wrong but i
do wish we had that same energy for
those people
you know dying in all these other
countries that's one of the biggest
reasons why i went to iraq because i was
against i mean here's a here's the
honest truth i was for the war in high
school because of all the influence
around me because i was saying the bible
justifies war and all that [ __ ] and then
when i became a real christian and re
read the bible and all this [ __ ] is like
wait a second
jesus doesn't want this [ __ ] to happen
yeah yeah and so i go out to the to you
know be a missionary you know
and all and
and all these other missionary kids in
training are telling me that what's
happening in iraq is justified and i'm
telling them dude
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
civilians not soldiers are being
murdered i've died to this day and we've
only been there at that point for like
six years yeah and they're telling me
yeah well you know this this book this
verse says that war is justified and all
this [ __ ] and that was one of the
biggest reasons why i went to iraq in
the middle of a war
because i wanted to be that represented
american representative that comes in
and i'm not trying to kill them
yeah yeah yeah and that was the impact i
had on on these people when i was in our
bill in northern iraq i mean it's so
easy nowadays to look at people as
memes and blurbs yes right and just uh
headlines and news
and you know here actually this is very
interesting so when i when i went to
pittsburgh
uh one of the things that
there's not much to do in pittsburgh
um
when you go to a town like that or even
like smaller towns or even cities like
that
people don't talk more uh they like
talking to you yeah they like talking on
the plane they like to spark up a
conversation with the person next to
them yeah i think a lot of people aren't
used to that
but you know i think whether it's
because we did missionary trips or
whatever or we kind of grew up in a
generation that was half in between
where somebody wants to talk to me i'll
talk to them it's not a nuisance yeah i
actually welcome it it's great to talk
um i was talking to a guy
about um it was just a bunch of
different subjects right
and then i think that sometimes when we
listen to the news and we hear about
these opposing uh ideas and views that
we have we think that the people who are
on the opposite side of us are [ __ ]
they're not there to listen to reason
and they can't have civil discourse
because it seems like that when you read
a facebook conversations and arguments
right so when i was on this plane i was
talking to this guy very very [ __ ]
nice guy
um and
the topic of kobe came up and he brought
it up right he was like god these
[ __ ] masks or whatever right this
[ __ ] is just the flu right yeah i was
like okay cool and i don't get mad about
stuff like that because number one he
wasn't angry at me yeah he wasn't saying
anything he was just stating his opinion
yeah yeah i was like oh why do you think
it's the flu it's like listen i looked
at the percentage of people who were
dying
not a lot of us out there and i was like
yeah i was like well it's not the flu
though right like i was like i had coven
and it was pretty devastating for me
and like um
can 95 mass clearly work it's been
proven that it does yeah and yeah you
know i don't think it's really the flu
like i've had it and we know people have
died from it too and i don't know
anybody who's died from the flu uh even
though there are people who have right
yeah
he goes yeah he goes he goes awesome
you're what we call a true believer i
was like what's a true believer i was
like you're scared of copen and i was
like i'm not scared of it right but i'm
i'm asian right and i was like me
wearing a mask it doesn't bother me
because you know oh yeah it's so normal
i was like for me i was like i'm not
sure if you know this right and uh he
travels a lot because he was uh he's in
um uh oil mining so he he goes from
project to project all over the world
yeah and i was like yeah like i mean you
you know i'm not sure if you know a lot
of age but we wear masks all the time
because it's not so much about like
i understand like when pandemic first
came out you people thought like oh you
think i'm disgusting or gross it's not
about that it's if i'm sick i don't want
to get you sick it's a common courtesy
it's just a common courtesy thing he
goes okay i can see that there was no
argument from this guy that was not it's
not how how everybody paints a human
being to be that's on the opposite he
just wanted we were just talking and
having a conversation yeah and that's
where we disagreed on something but we
just still continue to talk it's not
like he stopped talking to you on this
exactly he didn't call me dumb he didn't
call me stupid he's just like i disagree
and then we just kept continuing talking
foreign
team
quote-unquote is
you know to start immediately calling
that person an idiot or a murderer or
something yeah a murderer yeah he was
wearing his mask everything was fine and
then we started talking a little bit
more
and then
it was a really cool moment too where he
was talking about hey like and then he
started talking about racism right
because he was a large white male yeah
he goes like i don't think people in
america understand what racism really
looks like right yeah and he was like
i've been all around the world i travel
constantly right he goes you know when
i'm inside when i'm in south africa he
goes people are racist towards me and i
was like yeah i don't think racism is
akin to just one type of color right
like if you if you're prejudiced against
somebody because of a specific what this
color of the skin you're racist right or
whatever
and he goes well like if i go there they
have an equivalent to the n word for
white people over there he goes so i get
racially persecuted and i was like okay
you understand why though right he goes
because they don't like white people
saying have you heard of apartheid
and he was like what's that oh my god
i was like well you know
if you want to talk about racial
discrimination i'm talking about people
know stories about not and this is not
that very long ago that somebody who
looked like you would see uh let's say a
black and a white person together and
they would stone them yeah
like yeah that is why sometimes
your skin color
brings up a lot of rage and anger
because people who look like you
beat persecuted and and [ __ ] murdered
murdered them yeah so it doesn't come
from nowhere you know what i mean
and i was like that's why in south
africa when they see you and he was
telling me the story about how he was
what he did wasn't wrong right so
somebody in the in his mill or mine or
whatever
placed something was doing something
very dangerously and this because this
person was an african south african it
was an african person yeah and i was
like hey don't do it like that you have
to do it like this or you're going to
hurt yourself and then one of the
workers got into his face and started
[ __ ] cursing him out so you don't
[ __ ] talk to blah blah blah blah you
know in broken english or whatever yeah
and he was like i'm just doing my job
right i'm not justifying what that
person did but what he saw because he
doesn't understand your language is a
white man talking down yeah to this
young black man which is something that
he experienced his whole life yeah right
so i was like that's kind of where
that's coming from you know and he goes
like yeah i could see that yeah the
problem stems from a lot of white people
who are color blind
that's [ __ ]
to act like like oh everybody's the same
color but when you do that what are you
really doing in your head oh just
pretend this person's white yeah yeah
yeah or whatever right but then that's
not how society still works you want to
hear the kicker though so we were
talking about the stuff and then you
know we agreed on some other things here
and there too and they were talking
about and then he was talking about his
kid i was like hey you want to see my
kid cool [ __ ] kid black
bro that [ __ ] blew my [ __ ] mind yeah
it was half black i was like what the
[ __ ]
so yeah he's definitely not racist yeah
his wife is black yeah you know what i
mean but he he obviously has blind spots
yeah there's there's blind spots too and
there's like stuff that he doesn't
really see i think he wants to really
see the world in my personal opinion
when i met this guy he wants to see
people for what they are right and
that's how he judges people yeah but
he's also forgetting that in this
country there is a history with the
color of your skin and race that people
are not easily forgetting because there
are issues that still arise because the
color of your skin
just because you don't want to
acknowledge it doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist and it doesn't mean that
people will forget it just because you
did right and so that's the thing that
he's of kind of forgetting yeah that's
the that's the problem with quote
colorblind people yeah is is that um
they're not
they're they're pretending
even if they don't know it that this
person
has the same history as you has had the
same opportunities as you you're
assuming that they this person um has
gone through zero [ __ ] like racial
[ __ ] like you have yeah right but i
can tell he has great intentions
right and trying to judge people by the
their character which we try to do a lot
which is great right but then you have
to acknowledge the differences in
people's color right you have to
acknowledge the differences in people's
cultures
and what you have to acknowledge that
what makes us different and diverse is
what makes our society beautiful yeah
yeah you know but if you try to
make the world a psychological
homogenous country through your own mind
by pretending that's never going to work
out yeah and like you know
like i i think for me when i had that
conversation you know and just to wrap
it back to you it's like when you when
you went over to iraq it opened up your
mind because you had conversations with
people yeah that's the thing that a lot
of people are [ __ ] not even just
forgetting you're scared yeah you are so
scared to talk to people because you're
afraid that they're gonna say something
that's gonna oppose the way that you
think and you have nothing to say back
right and yeah you know because you
don't have your cue cards on exactly to
say all those talking points you don't
have google right you don't have time to
sit there read over this comment
multiple times over and try to write
back the perfect comment back right the
perfect rebuttal exactly with stuff that
probably you don't even believe in but
you just want to be right when somebody
is sitting across from you like or
sitting next to you on a plane here and
then all you have is your conversation
in the moment right and there are
probably more things that i could have
said that we when we were going back and
forth and by the same when i say back
and forth this was a very pleasant
conversation right like i said we
disagreed on probably 30 things in the
other 70 we agreed on but he didn't go
around calling me stupid he didn't feel
like we shook hands and said hey this
was a great conversation it was nice
talking to you yeah and i had another
conversation like just like this with
somebody in my uber and it was so
refreshing because i had to remind
myself that this isn't the [ __ ]
internet dude yeah there's real people
out here who want to talk to you and
even if they don't agree and this guy
was like hey you know what brother uh
you know i agree with most things you're
saying there's a few things i disagree
but man it was great talking to you man
and he appreciated the conversation and
i i loved it dude
right i think that's why we're being so
socially
uh what do you call it
i don't wanna
what's the regressive yeah yeah right
because on social media
you can announce who you are and what
you stand for on your profile
right and so people can easily read you
if they want to follow you or not or
interact with you
right but in real life right people
don't know that you know what you fly a
banner of liberal or conservative over
your head they don't know what you stand
for you got to get to know this person
right and i think a lot of people are
afraid to get to know people because of
what they might find in that way i might
not like something yeah because if if
this person i knew was on the internet i
would immediately condemn them and then
they live their lives like that when
they meet someone in real life yeah you
know like i think people just cannot
differentiate that
um
this social media culture with the way
we interact in real life they can't like
split themselves from that and not
realize it's not real yeah and i i was
talking so i i've been selling a bunch
of equipment on offer up and i and i um
uh sold a lens
and i was talking this lady where uh she
was like yeah like
she was asking what i do for a living i
was like i do video stuff he said well i
have a nephew who does twitch and he's
like pretty popular on there you know
people i don't know what popular twitch
is i don't know what the number is but
yeah it's like dude he's super funny and
his personality is really great like i i
watch some of his twitch stuff and he
has all these opinions about everything
he's super passionate but you talk to
him in person
about a single peep yeah i was like what
do you mean like he's like he doesn't
talk in person at all but when he's when
i see him on that camera he says all
these ideas they're they're pretty out
there but they're funny and then you
know he has opinions but you see him
when he's at a family party right i've
seen him with his friends he doesn't say
anything at all but i'm like oh that's i
was like and i told him i was like you
know why that is because there's no
consequence when you talk to a lens
right there's nobody saying back and
trying to refute what you're saying yeah
you don't have to stand your ground
right right and a lot of people cannot
do that and you see this a lot with like
political debates which i think are
really stupid when somebody like anybody
i don't know
there's that steven guy and then there's
you know ben shapiro right right you
know louder with crowder yeah that guy
you know i mean and you know he's trying
to pick on these like 18 year olds
right on subjects that he has like
papers and books and he's ready to argue
right yeah it's like
what's what's the point of this [ __ ] you
know what i mean like why even do this
like but you know these kids and i'll be
probably not their fault
these kids who feel like they have their
points ready they just come up and they
start blabbering emotions right somebody
who's talking facts or what they believe
are facts or stats yeah it doesn't
really work that way because you're too
used to being prepared having google
next to you to go ahead and prepare this
conversation when you're face to face
with somebody is completely different
and you will find out things that you
either like or don't like about yourself
and you have the ability to say like oh
[ __ ] maybe i was wrong here or i could
see where you're coming from and then
still be able to stand your point yeah
right there's nothing wrong with that
too i've had conversations with many
people where i was like oh [ __ ] maybe
i'm wrong about this stuff yeah you know
i think a lot of people have a problem
with finding out that they're wrong they
don't want to face i mean because they
feel embarrassment and shame
and that's all still perspective if you
are a learning person and you would
understand that there's no shame in
changing your mind yeah there's no shame
in learning and growing there's no shame
in refuting yourself
yeah you know your past self
you know and i say this too i hope you
weren't offended by the kim jong-il
thing dude that was i'm just telling you
a story about something that i pitched
years ago and once again kim jong-il is
an [ __ ] he's disgusting he's
deplorable and in the end he gets his
ass [ __ ] whooped all right and he
learns how wrong he is and he actually
becomes a feminist right
so that
also leads into the other thing we were
going to talk about a great tv show
that's on yes right now peacemaker shout
out to john cena and his amazing tweet
so here's here's all week in transition
john cena tweeted
that he wished she had the actual powers
of peacemakers so he can go into the
russia ukrainian conflict
and do something about it hashtag
peacemaker hpo max
he went there promoting his tv show now
here's the thing
bad timing but
great [ __ ] tv show
peacemakers is so interesting right like
i mean we could talk about i actually
get to watch the whole thing because
i've been moving a lot
but just in general from what i have
watched i've it's been very it's very
few and far between
nowadays even with something like loki
right
loki it took me a while to warm up but i
could see how great it was going to be
yeah peacemakers first scene love it
right i was like i love this i don't
know what the [ __ ] this is i [ __ ]
love it
the the initial conversation at the
hospital the fun janitor i was literally
cackling laughing yeah i'm like dude why
the [ __ ] is john cena so good
dude john uh uh uh
james gunn's writing bro he's just great
at this [ __ ] dialogue yeah and the
thing about james guntu sometimes i feel
like his stuff is a little over the top
peacemakers didn't feel this way yeah it
was meant for somebody like him like
yeah
like
this this character what i'm trying to
say is that
a lot of people
in in and how it opens is that people
see him as actually a villain they think
he's a super villain but in peacemaker's
minds he's like no i'm a superhero
why are you calling me a villain and all
these things
his arguments are so funny you kill
black people too so
at a higher rate i just find the next
time i'm out there i'm gonna kill more
white people how about that deal he goes
fine i like that it's good but it's it's
really great how they get into the
nuance of that argument is is that he's
like i just go where the crime goes
right and in his mind subconsciously
he's not realizing that he's just
attacking black people yeah right
and so the the show like opens up the
layers of peacemaker of who he really is
and where he comes from right
my
okay first what episode are you at right
now i'm on the fourth episode fourth
episode oh my gosh then i can't keep
going for that this has to be a spoiler
less okay review
of like halfway point we'll say because
there's only eight episodes okay so i'm
at the halfway point we'll talk up to
the point and then on the next one we'll
go even further once i finish it yeah
so like what we're going with it was is
that his father right what do you know
about his father so far peacemaker's
father
it's just about their relationship but i
don't know too much i i have to re-watch
everything because i'm watching it as
i'm moving right yeah so like
peacemaker's father is like a racist yes
he's like a piece of [ __ ] right yeah
especially like the way he treats him
yeah
right
i'm watching this right and i mentioned
it earlier about borat filming his piece
by the area i grew up in
this show is based
in the same area
that i grew up in in washington that's
so [ __ ] everyone has washed them
plates right but they all make sense
yeah they call it evergreen washington
which is like you know a fake city kind
of like metropolis it's supposed to be
like new york city or some [ __ ]
but
yeah like they they go through it and
they really capture
i don't know how i'm gonna say this
but the situation that white americans
are in white american men are in in this
day and age
right because everything a lot of white
americans have been told is like a lot
of entitlement [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
and if they work hard and put their head
down then they'll get this [ __ ] well
they do work hard
but they're not seeing any of the
benefits now they're getting a lot of
external factors telling them that these
are immigrant faults that these are
whatever this person that person this is
the democrats fault or whatever yeah you
know but we're also seeing it deeper
than that in his relationship with his
father because even you and i want to
get to know our father more than we know
yeah right there's a thing about men
like when i want to hear a news story
about my dad from a
long relative or whatever my ears are
open yeah i need to know i want to know
right because a lot of fathers in many
cultures don't say much
yeah they don't they don't really talk
about themselves we always hear stories
about them through somebody else right
it's like oh did you know your dad well
this guy beat up seven people at a bar
once it's a lady i'm like that's cool
never told me once i yeah whenever i
meet my dad's old friends they cannot
stop talking about how he was a pool
shark
and how he was so cool good at tangujang
he was
he was just taking everybody's money you
never taught me never told me about it
yeah that's like my grandpa too it's
like my grandpa was really really he was
like an expert fisherman yeah
never taught me how to fish and in fact
he thought i was [ __ ] annoying he
would never let me let him come with him
yeah
right so
in this case it follows this american
idea of this man trying to become a man
but what he knows about becoming a man
is a really bad example
he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah you
know and so his character in himself
says very shitty things to other people
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
that interaction that he had with i
think this is in the first episode too
with the neighbor
right
just [ __ ] calling it my old [ __ ] up
to go yeah it's like holy [ __ ] this guy
is such a his character is so complex he
is a he inherently thinks that he
everything he does is for the greater
good right did you see the suicide squad
the new one james gunn directed the
reason it's supposed to continue to
continue from that yeah i never got to
see it you gotta okay go back and watch
the suicide squad and then watch okay
watch keep continuing with the
peacemaker but you don't really have to
it's written well enough but if you
think it's it starts where that movie
ends right yes yeah
and so like
what what i see a lot is the like when i
see peacemaker i see a [ __ ] customer
at my store
that's crazy yeah this guy who thinks
he's the [ __ ] but really this society
really doesn't think [ __ ] about him and
so he has this angst and that character
is represented in the blonde
lady oh um
yeah i forgot her name
i'm blanking the [ __ ] out yeah we'll
come back but she gives him [ __ ] all the
time right he she represents the rest of
america that even white women find this
guy [ __ ] despicable and horrible you
know
and all the other characters in a way
like they they represent what you see in
this person and your first interactions
of this guy he's just eggnog obnoxious
slightly sex very sexist
and and and
just completely unaware of who he is
yeah yeah and as the show progresses
james gunn writes so well with teamwork
and team interaction that helps his
character arc you know but even in in
the middle you must have seen it too
where
he
he gets
back to his trailer home and he just
starts bawling yeah yeah yeah yeah right
yeah and what's he say like everybody
[ __ ] hates me
you know you're such a [ __ ] idiot or
whatever and he's jake paul yeah
he's revealing like these true emotions
of of of the truth of what's around him
but what he's actually ignoring yeah
which is so amazing to look at a
superhero tv show like what the [ __ ]
look at this depth of character there
yeah yeah yeah like everything else
around it you'll keep watching is so
[ __ ] nuts you know when he had that
breakdown moment when he was crying it
kind of reminded me it really did remind
me of social media people
right they have this like
i'm pretty sure this wasn't the thing
but you know when you watch something
you could take away things that you know
that attach it to your own personal life
um but it's like a lot of these social
media people they go i don't give a [ __ ]
about what anybody says about me i just
do what i do yeah but then i know these
people and it eats them up oh they they
care a lot they care so much and listen
i care a little bit too but
substantially a lot less than everybody
else because
we can read what's not true and be like
that's not true and you can laugh at it
exactly i'm like this is completely
false but there are sometimes some
comments i'll be i'll be honest i speak
for myself yeah i'll see i'm like huh
maybe i should look and look that over
about myself i really [ __ ] irritate
the [ __ ] out of me that day only because
it was so stupid they're like
the comment basically said that oh it's
like yeah i really want to like david
but he's so [ __ ] fake and i'm like
what right it's like all these stories
about him getting bullied and him
beating up people and i'm like wait
which is it
am i getting bullied or am i beating up
people because i'm pretty sure the
stories i'm stating i'm getting my ass
kicked a lot yeah you know what i mean
just because like when somebody says
this is the funny thing when somebody
tells a story it's like yeah i used to
get in fights i never said i won them
yeah yeah yeah you talk about the fight
but you don't end it
i never said i want these fights
i don't know what you're talking about
these are stories about me getting
bullied yeah you know i mean and then
literally i wrote to him and i was like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about it's
like clearly you don't listen to this
podcast but i was like if you want to
see and they're like oh david kickboxing
is a joke i was like cool well anytime
you want you meet me at a [ __ ] gym
we'll glove up and i'll [ __ ] you up
you're right whatever you want listen
i'm not saying i'm an amazing boxer
kickboxer but i'll tell you this right
now if you step into a gym and you have
never [ __ ] trained or even if you
train a year or two i will [ __ ] piece
you up i'm not i'm not saying i'm great
at this stuff but i love this sport yeah
you'll you'll find out really [ __ ]
soon but what i found was the core of
these type of comments that are coming
are people who hate to see somebody like
you have the confidence that you do no i
don't know what success that you do have
for yourself because i really feel like
this person who's writing this comment
looks exactly like this
they're like this is like impossible if
i can't do it you can't either yeah you
know it's like you you're fatter than me
yeah there's no way
it's like listen
and it's so funny too i could have so
many people come on this podcast
corroborate these stories you've been
around for half these [ __ ] stories
and it's still not true it's like i
don't know what else to do now at this
point i was like if you want me to live
your sorry existence so you could feel
better about your life it it's never
going to happen you're going to live in
that pity and sorrow every day so guess
what go out there and get bullied just
like me yeah get out there and get
punked and bullied but going back to
that like i see that guy as you know
these social media people yeah like when
i saw him i kind of i felt
bad for him right like if he's off the
phone like that was where he was away
from all these people he was around
where he can
put on this character in front of them
and portray who he is to them but when
he's alone and by himself
when these people don't have their
phones in front of them what are they
doing by themselves yeah what are they
thinking what do they actually think
about themselves
i always think about it with the haters
you know pretty much like when they say
[ __ ] to me or you or anybody else when i
see hate comments
i only see people talking to themselves
in the mirror dude once one of the
funniest comments i ever read too
was like um i told the story years ago
about it was like this thing i put in
the script about
this dude it was a korean guy who tried
to kill himself because he couldn't do
anything right yeah
but
i laughed at his face because it's true
because he tried to kill himself and he
couldn't do it yeah so and then this
person wrote they're like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] joking about suicide why don't
you kill yourself i was like wait wait
what
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] is this guy saying but
during that peacemaker moment if you've
ever seen this clip it's this moment of
uh
i was about to say jason paul jake paul
right jake paul and his brother logan
and jake paul's balling he's actually
crying on the podcast he goes i don't
understand
you know it's just really [ __ ] hard
man because all these people just
they're like we want you to lose you're
such an [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] dick i
don't know where they're coming from
like why do they want me to fail so much
and i'm like
i don't know maybe it's because the
persona you put on yeah
dude are you serious right now don't you
act like that to sell tickets yeah
because people buy your tickets because
they want to see you lose don't you know
that but that's the funny thing when i
was watching that i was like oh he's not
like some kind of sadistic
genius he's stupid
oh i thought he was like some marketing
g i was like oh this kid's just dumb
he's delusional yeah he really thinks
like the world is for him and there are
all these haters it's like no everyone
who buys your pay-per-view want to see
you get knocked the [ __ ] out yeah he's
bawling crying because he doesn't
understand why people hate him so much
and i'm like oh
he's an idiot
right he's not
as smart as i thought he was so
peacemaker when you get that's what i'm
saying yeah peacemaker is jake paul yeah
it's kind of [ __ ] crazy i was like
holy [ __ ] this is a very weird moment
when i saw that clip i was like that's
[ __ ] peacemaker yeah so i like i i
we'll have a part two on peacemaker
since you saw the first four yeah but
the next four i really want to talk
about
how peacemaker is the better chongqi
let's go baby peacemaker
did what shangchi tried to do and it did
it excellently oh man yeah and and we'll
talk about it i'm definitely not going
to roll on
but
we look for every opportunity man
well guys uh this wraps up this episode
of the genius brain podcast hope you
learned something new hope you walked
away with something you can find ed at
ed park v p people asking about your
podcast and when you're gonna upload a
damn episode hey man i'm uh
i'm going through some [ __ ]
and
i'm not in the mood
[Laughter]
but yeah i i i feel the pressure so i'll
continue i mean it's called bible study
at momo
and i you can find the links through my
instagram um there's three episodes i
recorded last year this time okay
but i i do have another episode
ready i'm just uh not sure how i want to
do it and i'll talk to you about it
maybe if you want to get involved with
it too okay yeah well well um we'll
figure that out and then we'll get it
going next time uh you guys could catch
genius brains every sundays at 12 p.m
remember stay interactive give us give
us a rating on itunes and spotify share
the podcast with everybody thumbs up the
video and talk to each other in the
comments because we're all about
communication just keep it nice and
peacemaker peaceful baby that's right
we'll see y'all next time peace peace